toute l'équipe s'active pour l'ouverture
de la piscine elle dispose de trois
bassins le plus grand découvrable de 25
mètres carrés un autre bassin une
pataugeoire cette dernière et non
utilisables pour limiter les risques de
propagation du virus
les extérieurs sont fermés également un
protocole sanitaire pour les usagers est
de rigueur
les clients n'utiliseront pas
les casiers faudra voir un sac et on
mettra les affaires dans le sac les gens
rentreront dans une cabine un parent
cabine habituellement la piscine et
d'une capacité d'accueil de 500
personnes avec la crise sanitaire la
capacité des vestiaires permet de
recevoir sur réservation 30 personnes
maximum
ils jetteront leurs masques et il faudra
se doucher savonnage obligatoire ça sera
contrôlée ils passeront ensuite ils
viendront nager au bassin un créneau
d'une heure 30 ouhlala si vous avez des
affaires du style blanche masques et
tout ça il faudra les désinfecter dans
un container on viendra nager ensuite au
bassin il y aura trois zones qui seront
dédiés une au jeu une aux nageurs
confirmés une plus nage détente pour
accéder à la piscine il faut réserver
minimum 48 heures à l'avancé
entre chaque créneau il y à débattement
d'une heure nécessaire pour la
désinfection des vestiaires le bassin et
les sanitaires ce qui provoque une files
d'attentes
je viens pour le premier jour parce que
la piscine me manquait depuis le début
du confinement
donc j'ai procédé à la réservation sur
internet
il est effectivement 12h20 le créneau
est censé durer à midi c'est un petit
temps de mise en route je pense les
créneaux de réservation sont disponibles
sur la plateforme sky point fr